ah more Supernatural must almost be
Christmas Time the movie opens up in
Truman High School where we see a group
of high school students having lunch in
the dining hall as they are gossiping
about their classmates a brunette girl
named Taylor approaches them to join
them for lunch however the group rejects
her asserting that their table is aeve
Free Zone feeling humiliated because she
doesn't know what aeve is Taylor turns
to another table where her obese
classmate April is eating alone having
witnessed the bullying April attempts to
console her advising her to not pay
attention to those people she also
extends an apology on behalf of the
bullies but this only enrages Taylor who
tells her not to feel sorry for her she
also calls her a pig before storming off
the next day Taylor is crying in the
bathroom when April confronts her from
behind she asks if she is really that
ugly Taylor apologizes for what she said
and tries to explain that she did not
mean it however April who is deeply
offended Ed grabs her by the neck and
bashes her face hard into the mirror she
then drags her across to a toilet where
she holds her head underwater until she
stops moving following this a thick
black tear drips from April's eyes as
she asserts you are ugly title
card in the aftermath of the incident
she is seen in a mental health facility
where her friend Sam pays her a visit
April however does not want want to
discuss the event any further she says
that she has already provided her
account to the police as well as medical
professionals but nobody believes her
they all think that she has gone crazy
however when Sam insists she eventually
reveals that she was possessed by some
kind of mysterious force during the
incident despite being physically
present she claims to have been mentally
absent she was able to see what she was
doing but could not control herself
furthermore she asserts that although
she and Taylor did not get along long
she never intended to kill her before
departing Sam inquires if April noticed
any smell of sulfur or black smoke that
day to which the latter replies no
following this Sam gets back to his
vehicle where his older brother Dean is
waiting for him he briefs him about the
situation suggesting that a demon may be
involved Dean thinks that it might be a
case of a troubled kid reacting to
bullying but Sam insists on a thorough
investigation the scene then cuts to a
flashback where we see young Sam and
Dean entering yet another new high
school Truman is the third school which
they have attended that Academic Year
Dean is not worried about fitting in
since their father has promised that
they will only be there two weeks tops
but Sam is tired of always being the new
kid as they enter the class he seems to
be nervous in front of his new pier
meanwhile in another classroom Dean
calls his teacher sweetheart immediately
inspiring all the girls to have crushes
on him while taking a seat Sam
accidentally drops a butterfly knife he
hurriedly retrieves it before the
teacher sees it but not before a
classmate named Barry cook notices Barry
seems to be fascinated by him so he
quickly introduces himself to Sam upon
settling down on their seats a fat boy
named Dirk starts bullying Barry from
behind seeing this Sam takes a stand for
his friend and tells Dirk to stop the
bully asks if he wants to take Barry's
place to which the latter intimidatingly
responds yeah back in the present Sam
and Dean disguised themselves in order
to enter Truman High School for their
secret investigation Sam poses as a
janitor while Dean plays the part of the
substitute gym teacher as he prepares
the students to play dodgeball Sam comes
in with a report no sulfur which means
no demonic activity Dean in the meantime
in a cooking class a bully student as
usual tells his nerd partner that he
needs to copy his homework again but
this time the nerdy kid responds with an
unsettling gaze and an evil smile not
long after he grabs the bully's hand and
shoves it into a running food processor
grinding it brutally the Grim sight
freaks out the entire class causing the
students to run away just then Sam
rushes into the scene only to discover
the nerdy kid has collapsed upon closer
examination he sees a black thick liquid
leaking out from the attacker's ear this
makes Sam realize that they are dealing
with some kind of ghost possession which
is rare but not unheard of later on Dean
digs up all the school files for
information he learns that the only
death incident on the school grounds was
the case of a self- kill back in 1998
here it is revealed that the one who
committed the unthinkable was Barry he
died in the same bathroom where April
killed Taylor all of these incidents
indicate that the mysterious entity is
targeting the nerds or underdogs to take
down the bullies the scene again takes
us back to the past in 1997 and we see
Barry walking down the hall shortly
after Dirk walks past and tackles him
down a group of girls who are standing
nearby laugh at him at the same time Sam
shows up and helps Barry pull everything
together as they begin talking the
ladder reveals that he will be out of
this school in 3 years he shares his
plan to relocate to Michigan state in
order to prepare for a career in
veterinary medicine believing that
animals are a lot nicer than people Sam
agrees and says I like platypuses and
Barry calls him a nerd on the other hand
Dean is making out with one of his
classmates named Amanda heckerling he
asks her out on a date later that night
but she refuses she mentions that her
parents don't allow her to be out after
10 as they Converse Amanda asks him
about his parents to which she replies
that his father is out of town for a
couple of weeks so he and his younger
brother are staying at a local Motel the
next day Barry and Sam are walking
together when they are stopped by Durk
he tries to instigate a fight with them
but Sam firmly refuses angered by this
Dirk delivers a powerful punch to his
face sending him to the ground but
before Sam can retaliate a teacher
arrives at the scene and escorts Dirk
away later when Dean becomes aware of
the incident he intends to punish Dirk
going to make him pay Sam but his
brother stops him from doing so Sam
claims that he does not want to leave a
bad impression and that he just wants to
be normal changing the subject he asks
about Dean's relationship with Amanda in
response the latter reveals that she
wants him to meet her parents but he
does not want to afterwards Sam is
summoned by the English teacher Mr Wyatt
in order to discuss an essay assignment
he tells him that the essay was was
supposed to be non-fiction unlike what
Sam wrote despite this he Praises his
writing skills and asks if he has
thought of pursuing the craft however
Sam says he can't mentioning his
obligation to the family business
hearing this Mr Wyatt asks what he
really wants to do when the boy remains
silent he goes on to say that he was
supposed to be a surgeon just like his
dad but that wasn't him as a result he
advises Sam to live the life he wants to
live in the present the brothers salt
and burn burn Barry's remains once back
in the car Sam feels guilty as he
believes that he could have helped Barry
if their father let them stay a little
while longer Dean then tries to console
him pointing out that there was nothing
he could have done according to him
Barry was already on anti-anxiety meds
as his parents were splitting and the
school was hell due to all of this he
just wanted to get out of his
problematic life just then Sam remembers
the conversation he had with Mr Wyatt in
the past so he decides to pay a visit to
the teacher a upon arriving at truman
high school he walks down the hallway in
search of Mr Wyatt when he is suddenly
stopped by a girl she asks him for
directions after which she addresses him
by his name this surprises Sam but
before he can comprehend the situation
the girl suddenly stabs him in the chest
with a pen in a swift Act of Defense Sam
fills the girl's mouth with salt
expelling the ghost from her body if she
wasn't a ghost that would have been
awkward following this he retreats to
Dean who then hands him some whiskey
asking him to apply it to his wounds
Dean then goes through some files and
discovers a commonality all the
possessed students ride the same school
bus which is driven by Dirk's father the
duo then goes to check the bus where
they find a new permit that is
registered in the name of Dirk this
triggers Sam's recollection of a past
confrontation with Dirk one day Barry
was being bullied by him as usual when
Sam showed up he was pushed to the
ground as well however he stood right
back up and fought the bully he
delivered some powerful punches and
eventually defeated him upon witnessing
this all the students started to make
fun of Dirk regarding him as a weak guy
Derk the dick got a small dick in the
present the brothers find the address to
Dirk's place so they head towards it
there they meet with his father who
reveals that Dirk died at the age of 18
after years of abusing alcohol and drugs
he laments that the school was never
easy for Dirk and that people called him
Dirk of the jerk no no it was small dick
Durk you heard it here a nicknamed Sam
came up with after beating him in a fist
fight in addition the father discloses
that his wife died of cancer when Durk
was 13 and since he had to do three jobs
he was unable to take proper care of his
son realizing that Dirk's spirit is
causing all of this Dean cuts to the
Chase and asks where he is buried in
response the father tells him that Dirk
was cremated but he kept a lock of his
hair in his Bible on the bus meanwhile
the very same bus is transporting a
sports team to an away game on the way
the substitute driver Eddie has black SL
ludge dripping from his nose indicating
that he is possessed by the ghost as a
result he speeds the bus sending the
passengers into a state of panic a short
while later Sam and Dean somehow managed
to stop the bus by blowing at its tires
with the help of spikes as soon as Eddie
walks out of the vehicle the brothers
tie him up with a rope Dean then gets on
the bus to find the Bible while Sam
holds the possessed guy at gunpoint
however the mere rope is not enough to
hold Eddie as he soon frees himself this
leaves Sam with no choice CH but to gun
him down Dean shortly after Dirk Spirit
possesses a member of the sports team
and comes to attack the brothers again
while Sam tries to fight the possessed
individual Dean manages to locate Dirk's
hair in Eddie's pocket Sam he
immediately sets it a blaze finally
freeing the spirit in the final scene
Sam finally visits Mr Wyatt who has
grown very old he thankss him for his
great advice that one should make his or
her own choices the teacher asserts that
the only thing that really matters is if
one is happy he then asks if he is happy
but Sam is unable to answer subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching